[Musique]
je vois pas été ce média donc j'ai 28
ans et gérant de la société d'état une
performance
spécialisée en fait dans le lavage la
rénovation et la protection des
véhicules mais détails mais en fait
c'est un terme anglais désignant un
processus de rénovation qu'on applique
sur les véhicules de façon à le
restaurer comment à son état neuf voire
même au delà du neuf est décidé de
m'inscrire dans la catégorie création
d'emplois au début de l'activité donc
j'étais seul et à l'heure actuelle donc
on est à quatre salariés
nous accueillons pas mal de stagiaires
via les missions locales et d'ailleurs
le cinquième salariés que nous allons
embaucher d'ici janvier et la stagiaire
qu'on a découvert on va dire par rapport
à la mission locale de saint claud team
suite à mes études donc j'ai pu
continuer cinq ans dans une grosse
société de rénovation bâtiment mais je
n'étais pas vraiment passionné par le
bâtiment en fait on a fait une rupture
conventionnelle avec mon ancien
directeur par rapport au montage du
dossier paul otages donc je me suis fait
accompagner par la boutique de gestion
principalement est un petit peu aussi la
chambre des métiers
donc dès que les chefs d'entreprises
donc c'est surtout beaucoup de cheveux
blancs on va dire beaucoup de tracas
fava le soutien média
avec mon équipe également c'est vrai
qu'on a vraiment très bien évolué et
d'enlèvements bien reconnus par rapport
aux clients professionnels
donc je vais gagner le challenge des
créateurs car actuellement on a déjà
créé
cinq emplois et on compte pas s'arrêter
là en fait on envisage prochainement
très prochainement donc d'ouvrir un
centre de formation donc on sera le
premier centre de formation de dating
sur l'île de la réunion et donc on
proposera des formations aux jeunes en
difficulté des associations et aux
différents professionnels également et
puis on envisage également la création
d'un deuxième centre détail performance
en fait dans le sud de l'île d'ici fin
d'année 2010 9 donc c'est un centre on
pourra également donc embauché en fait
les jeunes qu'on aura x men ou même
[Musique]
bonjour et la magie rachète 34 ans
gérant de la société d'érotique nous
travaillons principalement dans
l'installation électrique et les
accusations de réseaux
télécommunications réseaux cuivre fibres
et même internet
on a créé une entreprise depuis le 1er
mars 2017
on a commencé à travailler et dignement
mon mari et moi sur ces chantiers plus
tard ont été amenés à développer notre
activité et à embaucher d'autres
salariés
si j'ai choisi de concourir dans la
catégorie création de l'emploi
c'est parce que ben de plaine et
dernière on la recrue commencé à
recruter des salariés au moins du lait
on a recruté deux techniciens
supplémentaires et en cette année 2010 8
on est passé à quatre salariés de
l'entreprise et
au mois d'octobre on l'a pris une
apprentie qui a fait ses débuts chez
nous avant de créer l'entreprise j'étais
vendeuse
suite à la naissance de mon petit j'ai
arrêté mon travail jeu et jeter
demandeur d'emploi pour la création
d'entreprise j'ai bénéficié que de
l'aide du pôle emploi la cre vu que
j'étais demandeur d'emploi en tant que
gérante
j'ai énormément de responsabilités c'est
ce qui nous plaît beaucoup dans cette
entreprise
je m'organise comme je veux au niveau de
mes horaires je veux passer beaucoup
plus de temps avec mes enfants et
financièrement c'est mieux je vais
gagner le challenge créateur car depuis
que j'ai créé l'entreprise
j'étais amené à embaucher des salariés
on a commencé la société avec un
technicien et aujourd'hui on a à notre
actif cinq techniciens
on va tout faire pour avoir d'autres
chantiers est pas là pour pouvoir par la
suite embaucher d'autres techniciens et
même les former
[Musique]